en el vídeo anterior hablamos de cómo
construir una celda voltaica también
conocida como celda galvánica que
esencialmente es una batería donde
separamos las reacciones de oxidación y
de reducción y las conectamos con un
alambre los electrones perdidos por el
zinc son forzados a viajar a través del
alambre para que los iones de cobre
puedan quedarse con ellos y los iones de
cobre sean reducidos quizá todo eso les
ha generado algunas preguntas como por
ejemplo si esta es una batería cuál
sería la terminal positiva y cuál sería
la negativa de voltaje tiene la batería
bueno antes que nada pensemos en las
terminales cuál creen que sería la
positiva y cuál la negativa los invito a
ponerle pausa al vídeo y pensar un poco
de dónde viene la corriente eléctrica y
hacia dónde va
bueno los electrones inician en la
terminal negativa empiezan en la placa
de zinc entonces este es el electrodo
negativo de la batería o también se le
conoce como ánodo
este es el ánodo
del otro lado los electrones llegan a
esta placa de cobre así que este es el
electrodo positivo también se le conoce
como cátodo
acá todo muy bien ahora cuál es el
voltaje el voltaje depende de la
concentración de iones de zinc y vellón
es de cobre que tengamos también depende
de la presión y la temperatura pero todo
eso ya se ha estandarizado y pueden
simplemente buscar el potencial
eléctrico estándar para cada una de las
reacciones parciales busquen por tablas
de potencial estándar y encontrarán un
montón de voltajes para diferentes iones
que son mediciones en relación a un
electrodo estándar de hidrógeno que
tanto tomará este ión incluso
encontrarán el valor para esta reacción
los iones de cobre con el número de
oxidación 2 + tomarán estos electrones
para convertirse en cobre sólido y
relativo al electrodo estándar de
hidrógeno eso tiene un voltaje de 0.34
me gustaría que comparemos los voltajes
que ocurren en esta celda y así
obtengamos la fuerza electromotriz total
es decir el voltaje total con el que
ocurre la reacción redox la fuerza con
la que empujaremos a los electrones a
través del alambre si buscan la reacción
de zinc en las tablas de potenciales
estándar encontrarán que su potencial es
de menos 0.76 pero tengan cuidado porque
si tienen este número
eso significa que les están dando la
reacción opuesta es decir la reacción
que aparte de lyon de zinc tomando
electrones para convertirse en zinc
sólido pero nosotros necesitamos la otra
reacción la que ocurre en nuestra celda
galvánica entonces el potencial de esta
reacción es lo negativo de este así que
el voltaje es de 0.76
es positivo
esto ocurrirá con una fuerza
electromotriz o energía por colom
relativa 0.76 volts y esto ocurrirá con
una fuerza electromotriz de 0.34 volts
si combinamos eso la reacción total
ocurrirá con una fuerza electromotriz o
también llamada diferencia de potencial
eléctrico entre la que hay de este lado
y de este otro entonces si sumamos estos
dos y también conocemos la concentración
estándar que puede ser 1 molar es decir
de un molde iones por cada litro de
solución al estar a una temperatura y
presión estándar entonces podemos decir
que hemos construido una batería de 1.1
volts esa es la suma de estos dos claro
hay otras formas en las que pueden
llegar a este resultado por ejemplo
pueden literalmente usar un voltímetro
para medir la corriente sin electrones y
con electrones en su celda así pueden
medir la diferencia de voltajes entre
las terminales así es como se hace en
una
batería tradicional